Pourquoi les meilleurs sont-ils meilleurs?
Avez-vous remarqué que les meilleures élèves ont
plus souvent l’occasion de s’améliorer que les
moins bons? Par exemple, on donnera plus souvent
la parole à l’élève qui s’exprime le mieux dans
une langue étrangère lui permettant de ce fait de
progresser un peu plus à chaque prise de parole?
Avez-vous remarqué que les meilleurs sportifs
ont l’occasion d’intégrer les meilleures
structures qui leur permettent de progresser?
Avez-vous remarqué que les personnes
riches ont plus d’occasions d’augmenter
leur richesse que les personnes pauvres
qui de ce fait le resteront?
Car on donnera à celui qui a, et il
sera dans l’abondance. Mais à celui qui
n’a pas, on ôtera même ce qu’il a.
Robert Merton, sociologue américain,
a publié en 1968 un article dans lequel il
explique un phénomène d’avantage cumulatif
qu’il observe dans le champ scientifique.
Il appelle ce processus l’Effet Mathieu en
référence au verset biblique de
l’évangile de Saint-Mathieu :
Car on donnera à celui qui a, et il sera
dans l’abondance. Mais à celui qui n’a pas,
on ôtera même ce qu’il a.
Dans cette vidéo, je vous présente
l’Effet Mathieu dans les sciences tel
que l’a formulé Robert Merton.
Robert Merton explique dans cet article
qu’au niveau des récompenses scientifiques,
ce ne sont pas toujours les plus méritants
qui obtiennent la reconnaissance. Il existe
des mécanismes psychosociaux qui biaisent les
processus de récompense, qui influent ensuite
sur les systèmes de communication de la science
et mettent en place une sélection sociale.
Merton se base principalement sur des entretiens
réalisés par son épouse, également sociologue,
Harriet Zuckerman. Celle-ci, dans le cadre de
ses recherches sur les avantages cumulatifs,
a rencontré différents lauréats
de prix Nobel aux Etats-Unis.
Que cela soit en physique ou en médecine,
les interviews montrent que les scientifiques
célèbres jouissent d’un crédit disproportionné
pour leur contributions scientifiques tandis
que des scientifiques relativement inconnus
ont proportionnellement très peu de crédit
pour des contributions comparables.
Cela peut particulièrement bien s’observer
dans les travaux collectifs, où le scientifique le
plus reconnu se verra attribuer une grande partie
des mérites, même si son rôle a été mineur
dans la co-écriture de la recherche.
Les découvertes simultanées et indépendantes
sont porteuses d’un mécanisme similaire.
Des chercheurs font la même découverte au même
moment de manière totalement indépendante. C’est
généralement le scientifique le plus renommé
qui se verra gratifié de la découverte.
Ce processus nuit au chercheur novice dont les
travaux manquent de visibilité, éclipsés par
ceux des grands noms de la discipline.
Toutefois, les travaux collectifs peuvent
devenir des atouts pour le scientifique
débutant. Celui qui a été associé à des
scientifiques importants et qui persévère
à produire des travaux de qualité peut voir
ses travaux passés reconnus rétroactivement et
valorisés d’autant plus que des grands noms y
étaient associés. Dans ce cas, la reconnaissance
a été simplement postposée, déplacée.
Merton constate dans les témoignages qu’il
analyse qu’un effet de compensation est bien
présent dans le système de récompense. Les
travaux d’un scientifique sont sous-évalués
au début de sa carrière tandis que ses
travaux ultérieurs seront surestimés.
Cette réalité colle particulièrement bien à ce
verset de l’évangile de Saint-Mathieu puisque
ceux qui ont auront encore plus et ceux qui
n’ont presque rien auront encore moins.
Ce mécanisme inéquitable est parfois pris
en considération par les scientifiques
eux-mêmes qui y voient une double injustice dans
l’attribution des mérites. Donnant trop aux uns et
pas assez aux autres. Certains scientifiques
reconnus refusent même la co-écriture de
certaines publications afin de ne pas faire de
l’ombre à leurs plus jeunes collègues.
Ce dysfonctionnement dans le système de
récompense a des répercussions dans le système
de communication dans le monde scientifique.
Le phénomène influence non seulement les carrières
mais aussi la visibilité des contributions
de chacun. Les publications des scientifiques
renommés ont une meilleure publicité que celles
de ceux qui n’ont pas encore été reconnus.
De cette manière, le fait qu’un grand nom
s’associe à un novice peut apporter une visibilité
et donc une possibilité de reconnaissance des
travaux de ce dernier. Merton insiste sur le
fait que pour autant que l’Effet Matthieu soit
dysfonctionnel pour le système de récompense , il
est fonctionnel dans le système de communication.
C’est-à-dire qu’il permet un tri de l’information.
Cela est d’autant plus important que dans le
champ scientifique, très peu de publications
sont lues par les scientifiques eux-mêmes. On
parle par exemple de moins de 1% en chimie ou en
psychologie. Les sociologues Stephen et Jonathan
Cole ont calculé un indice de visibilité des
publications scientifiques et ils ont en effet
constaté que plus le rang d’un scientifique
est élevé, plus ses travaux sont diffusés dans la
communauté scientifique. Les prix Nobel obtiennent
un score de 85 alors que les physiciens jamais
récompensés obtiennent une note de visibilité
de 17. Et à chaque nouvelle récompense, la
visibilité d’un scientifique est renforcée.
Merton insinue à ce titre que l’explosion
du nombre de publications encourage l’effet
Matthieu dans cette fonction de mise
en lumière de certaines publications,
permettant à chacun de savoir où porter son
attention. Autrement dit, dans un contexte de
concurrence et de profusion des travaux, l’effet
Matthieu permet aux scientifiques d’identifier
plus facilement les publications qui pourraient
se révéler être déterminantes dans leur domaine.
L’effet Matthieu est donc un mécanisme important
pour la science. En effet, la science est une
démarche collective où les connaissances
sont produites sur base de contributions
multiples et de travaux réalisés par d’autres. La
communication et l’échange entre les scientifiques
sont donc primordiaux. L’effet Matthieu par la
“curation” des contenus qu’il permet est de ce
fait un mécanisme qui permet à la science de se
développer en tant que construction sociale.
Merton va encore plus loin. Il dit que la
visibilité des travaux des grands noms d’une
discipline n’est pas seulement dû un effet de
halo. Il veut dire que le seul prestige social
des hommes de science n’est pas la seule cause du
crédit accordé aux travaux scientifiques. Il y a
également des causes psychologiques et sociales
en jeu. Les grands noms ont également intégrés par
socialisation auprès de leurs mentors certaines
attitudes et valeurs qui les destinent à produire
des travaux significatifs et déterminants pour
leur discipline. Merton dit que les grands noms
dégagent un charisme qui n’est que la traduction
de certaines normes et valeurs. Celles-ci
correspondent à un développement du sens du goût,
à l’acquisition de certains schéma de pensées
et de langage, à un culte de l’effort qui les
portent vers les enjeux fondamentaux et non les
questions périphériques de leur domaine d’étude.
Parce qu’ils ont une certaine représentation
de leur métier et de leurs travaux, les grands
scientifiques sont dotés d’une volonté et d’une
confiance en eux sans faille qui leur permet à la
fois de surmonter les difficultés de tout ordre
mais aussi de persévérer à trouver LA découverte
déterminante et fondamentale dans leur discipline.
Ils n'hésitent donc pas à refuser des recherches
hasardeuses qui n’ont que peu de chance d’aboutir
sur des découvertes majeures. Ils affrontent
les critiques qui ciblent leur procrastination
parce qu’ils veulent être déterminants.
Et c’est parce qu’ils ont été formés aux
côtés de grands noms, qu’ils deviennent
eux-mêmes des scientifiques de premier
plan. Une grande majorité de lauréats
au prix Nobel, ont travaillé plus jeune
pour des prix Nobel qui ont ainsi assuré leur
socialisation et leur future reconnaissance.
L’Effet Matthieu est en plus un cas particulier de
prophétie auto-réalisatrice qui, pour rappel, est
un énoncé faux qui devient vrai par le seul fait
qu’il soit énoncé. Par exemple, un média annonce
une pénurie, peu probable, de papier toilette.
Cette pénurie se réalise uniquement parce que
les auditeurs ont entendu cette information et se
sont rués dans les grandes surfaces à la recherche
de papier toilette par peur d’en manquer et
en ont donc provoqué de ce fait la rupture.
Prophétie auto-réalisatrice.
De la même manière, parce qu’ils sont annoncés
comme de grands noms, l’effet Matthieu pousse les
scientifiques de renom à assurer des publications
de qualité, d’une part. Et d’autre part, la
publication de ces travaux est attendue par le
public qui y accordera un temps et un engagement
important pour les comprendre permettant de cette
manière de déceler toute la profondeur
du travail accompli. Un tel crédit et une
attention de ce niveau n’auraient sans doute
pas été accordés à des travaux moins attendus
et auraient donc empêché d’y découvrir
certaines pépites et donc de les reconnaître
comme déterminants pour la science. Et on retrouve
ici, un dysfonctionnement puisque l’effet Matthieu
empêche la prise en considération de découvertes
importantes mais réalisées par des inconnus.
Pour terminer, on peut parler des effets
institutionnels et de sélection sociale de l’effet
Matthieu. Obéissant au principe énoncé tout au
long de cette vidéo qui fait qu’on ne donne qu’aux
riches, les grandes universités auront tendance
à recruter les scientifiques les plus réputés.
Ces universités deviendront des pôles concentrant
toutes les ressources intellectuelles tandis que
des universités de second ordre seront sans cesse
pillées de leurs meilleurs éléments. En parallèle,
les moyens matériels et financiers seront plus
facilement accordés aux grandes universités du
fait de la réputation de leurs membres.
Ceux-ci auront donc plus de facilité à
réaliser de grandes découvertes que leurs
collègues issus des universités de second
plan entretenant ce mécanisme d’avantage
cumulatif qu’est l’effet Matthieu.
Cette publication montre bien que le travail de
Merton s’inscrit dans le paradigme fonctionnaliste
car elle appréhende la réalité sous l’angle de
des fonctions remplies par l’Effet Mathieu et des
dysfonctionnements auxquels il conduit.
En tant que prof de sciences sociales,
je trouve que l’effet Matthieu est un mécanisme
psychologique, social et institutionnel bien utile
pour comprendre bon nombre de phénomènes tels que
certaines inégalités scolaires ou sociales.
Cette vidéo est terminée… Abonnez-vous
si vous l’avez appréciée.
N’oubliez pas de consulter le descriptif
où vous trouverez l’article original de
Merton. La Sociothèque vous offre aussi
sa traduction, réalisée par ma chère
épouse, ainsi que différentes références. Je vous
mets également le lien vers un résumé de l’article
réalisé par les élèves de 5e année sciences
sociales du Collège Visitation-La Berlière. Merci
donc à Sophie, Léana, Liam, Alexandra, Elise,
Elwann, Emilie et Kylian pour ce travail.
Et je vous dis à très bientôt dans de nouvelles
vidéos consacrées aux sciences sociales,